how much money you make and the extent
to which you you
you crush it will be dictated by how big
the arbitrage
what's going on everyone i'm gonna be
talking to you about my fa one of my
favorite topics
um arbitrage and so the first time i
heard
this word uh was actually in a fancy
dinner i was sitting at and i was like i
don't know what's going on
and these dudes in finance were talking
about derivatives and crazy stuff right
they just kept saying arbitrage and i
was like what is it you know like like
finally i was like what does that mean
um and they were like oh it's like when
you just take advantage of an
inefficiency in a marketplace and i was
like
how and so then they explained it to me
and they're like well it's sort of like
when you go on ebay right and you can
buy something for five dollars
and then you can take the same thing and
then just go into amazon and sell it for
fifty dollars well that would be a big
example but you get the idea
where you buy for five and you sell for
50 and it's because there's an
inefficiency in a marketplace where
there's
that's where the arbitrage happens right
and so the definition of arbitrage
is where you buy in one market
right at one cost and then you sell
in another market at another cost so you
sell high
and you buy low pretty simple right
everyone understands that that makes
shakes that should make sense and here's
you in the middle making
all your money being happy yeah there's
you all right so
that is basically what arbitrage means
but the more i thought about this
concept the more i realized
that all businesses arbitrage and
how much money you make and the extent
to which you you
you crush it will be dictated by how big
the arbitrage is
right even if you think about basic
business a service business
you're buying labor in the labor market
this is market one this is why this is
important is that you're buying and
selling between different markets
all right this was a point of nuance
that i didn't understand when they first
told me
how this worked and i also didn't want
to ask because i was embarrassed that
i didn't know what i mean so hopefully
you can watch this and not be
embarrassed if someone says it all right
so market one and market two so there's
an inefficiency this little line here
is the inefficiency between the
marketplace what you're buying it when
you're selling it
right right and so market one can be a
labor market you're buying labor at x
price and you know that you can sell the
labor at another price to market too
right and then that's how you make a
profit but every business fundamentally
works this way
i can buy from a manufacturer for a
dollar and sell it over to market or
market number two for five dollars right
now and even the manufacturer
buys from raw ingredient producers
who buy it from farmers at one dollar
and sell it for five dollars right
and so that's the game that continue
gets played between market one and
market two
and a a supply chain is literally a
series of markets
in a row of markets buying and selling
buying and selling and buying and
selling and then the person in the
middle the business owner is technically
arbitraging all of these things
right right okay now here's where i
think this is interesting
there are two so take this concept
pocket it in your mind for a second
and so one of the concepts that i've
tried to explain um and i'm i'm
partially making this video so that i
can
i know that i learn things better when i
teach them all right so it's the
difference between economic profits
and accounting profits if anyone took
economics
if you did right then they would talk
about this
and the difference i'll start with
accounting profits because it's it's the
easier one to understand they're not
hard to understand but it's the easier
one all right
so economic profits versus accounting
accounting profits
are revenues minus all costs right that
is an accounting
profit right that's what most of us do
when we do our tax returns that is an
accounting profit
simple everyone should understand that
an economic
profit is where you take the revenue
minus the explicit cost of doing
business
and then you also subtract out the
opportunity cost which is the
implicit cost of using the resources
that you have
in that particular market or path versus
another opportunity
so let me give you an example so let's
say
uh you owned a paper mill right and
your company owned a forest and that's
where they cut the trees down and then
they turned it into paper
right simple now the economic profits of
that business the
opportunity cost that would be factored
into that economic profit
is whether or not you could make more
money just selling timber
right or selling sawdust or selling wood
those would be different examples of
things that you could do with the
existing resources you have
which is this guy in the middle here
he's got resources he's got people he's
got
maybe equipment skill sets talent etc
that if he were to apply those skills
to a different market he could then make
more money
and that is the difference between
economic profits and accounting profits
and the reason this is important to me
as an entrepreneur is that when i'm
looking at
what i want to get into right with what
things are interesting to me or for
investing because i invest in
businesses now which is kind of wild to
me um but anyways
is that i'm looking is this given these
resources of humans and skills and
and equipment and software and
everything we're currently pursuing
arbitrage opportunity a right
but what if with these same skills
i could have arbitrage opportunity b
where i'm buying in this market
for rock bottom prices and there's
another market over here
that is paying top dollar right so
between the first example i have where
it's a
it's a normal amount of money that's
being made compared to this
arbitrage opportunity i would want to be
in this one
right now what's going to dictate
whether or not it's going to be one of
these markets versus one of these
markets
well the growth of the marketplace
overall
there are growing markets like online
fitness is a growing market
right and so it means that there's
likely
going to be arbitrage a greater degree
of arbitrage because there's going to be
more demand
and so if i can find markets where i
feel like there's more demand
for the same things that i can buy
cheaply then i want to go to those
things and so when i'm thinking about
all opportunities because i think that
that's one of the biggest superpowers
that we have to have as entrepreneurs is
not
sure like right now i could go and run a
gym and make money i could i could also
run a massage parlor and make money i
could also run
a supplement company make money i do
that too right i could run a lot of
different businesses to make money
but of all the opportunities under the
sun of all the different ways i could
make money which is the best
given my resources skills talent team
etc and then if i look at all of those
things on a board these are the things
that we're absolutely amazing at
and these are the different arbitrage
opportunities that exist
which of these arbitrage opportunities
will be best fit
for the skills talents traits team etc
that i have
and then by answering that question
we'll inherently answer the
very important question which is what
can we be the best in the world at
and so i think for me this has been a
really valuable concept to understand is
that
all businesses arbitrage it all
functions off of an information
advantage between the buyer
and the seller the bot sorry the seller
always has the information advantage or
many times has the information advantage
and so fundamentally when you find out
that an iphone costs 17
to make people are shocked by this but
that's because
there's obviously other costs besides
the manufacturing obviously
but all big businesses run off of
extraordinary degrees of arbitrage right
facebook is able to have eyeballs and
sell eyeballs at a significant amount
cheaper than it costs them to
manufacture them
right right uh verizon it costs them
pennies to add another user to their
base
and so the reason this is important for
me to at least express is that for a
very long time
when i was when i was earlier on in my
career i had these weird morals and
ethics around how much more i could
charge for something
the reality is there is no limit it is
simply based on the market demand
and so whether it costs you a penny to
make something that's worth a thousand
dollars or cost you a penny to make
something worth two pennies
that price that you charge should never
be in any way relation to what it costs
you and only
related to what the market will allow
and then it's up to us as entrepreneurs
to look at
which arbitrage opportunities exist
between marketplaces
that best fit our skill sets and by
doing that we will then find ourselves
in the best opportunity vehicle for us
to grow in the long term and probably
make the most money
so anyways i hope that was valuable for
you i hope this made sense for me this
is a topic that i love talking about
um and i hope that you find value in
that and otherwise have an amazing day
i'm rooting for you keeping awesome
leave a like comment or review already
your subscription or
subscribe or tap the button or all the
stuff um keeping awesome
catch you soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you